لقد قلت اليوم كما تقول في كثير من الأحيان
أنك تعيش في سنغافورة، من أي أمة
أنت مواطن سنغافورة، هل أنت
مواطن من أي دولة أخرى، لا سيدي، هل
سبق لك أن تقدمت بطلب للحصول على
الجنسية الصينية، عضو مجلس الشيوخ أنا أخدم أمتي في
سنغافورة، لا، لم أفعل  لديك
جواز سفر سنغافوري نعم، وقد خدمت في
الجيش لمدة عامين ونصف في
سنغافورة، هل لديك جواز سفر آخر، هل لديك
أي جوازات سفر أخرى من أي
دولة أخرى، لا، أيها السيناتور، زوجتك
مواطنة أمريكية، أطفالك
مواطنون أمريكيون، صحيح، أليس كذلك؟  تقدمت بطلب للحصول
على سفينة American Citi، ليس ليس جيدًا
بعد، هل
سبق لك أن كنت عضوًا في
مجلس الشيوخ عن الحزب الشيوعي الصيني، أنا
سنغافوري، لم يسبق لك أن كنت
مرتبطًا أو تابعًا
للحزب الشيوعي الصيني، لست عضوًا في مجلس الشيوخ مرة أخرى،
أنا سنغافوري